so James just as a start I mean you've
got a really interesting background I
mean MD PhD you know academic positions
at UCSF Stanford Harvard and then went
to become an entrepreneur because I'll
tell you a little bit about why you made
that transition and what you saw the
kind of the differences in impact
between being in academia and being an
entrepreneur your founding and running a
small company well so the my academic
interests were not in business but were
in science and medicine I started out
with a curiosity about becoming a
scientist and physician in an academic
Medical Center and went through the
whole you know multi-year prolonged
adolescence that that required in order
to get trained as both an MD and a PhD
and then when the job offers came I got
job offers from a number of universities
including Harvard and Wash U and
University of Washington and none of
them felt particularly compelling
because in all of these situations I
never felt that the science and medicine
would actually meet one another I
thought that there was gonna be a
science component and there's gonna be a
medicine component but there were two
separate jobs I could be working in the
film industry on one and working as
assigned to honey other they didn't seem
to relate to one another and that was
back in the in the in the 80s and 90s
when I think that truly was more of a
two solitudes
field between science and medicine so
out of curiosity I went to visit a
number of companies and loaned my behold
I felt that within these companies this
was where science and medicine actually
met one another and actually had a
dialogue and a conversation whereby the
clinician could think about clinical
trials and think about clinical
development from a scientific viewpoint
and the scientists could think about
what they were doing with an output
towards patients and in the end
Grob that's what drove me out of the
University and into companies the other
thing I will fail and I don't know how
many of you are university professors
are working in the universities were
awfully slow and I just felt that the
the pace of which things happen there
were glacial and that also bothered me
so things move faster in a start-up
things move faster in companies and I
thought the medicine and science could
meet one another now I think even the
more interesting transition is I mean
you're CEO of two biotech companies one
of which you went through the whole
taking public been very very successful
and
then did a transition that I rarely see
it's very common in the
biopharmaceutical industry for people to
go from large companies senior
executives at a Merck and a Pfizer at
GlaxoSmithKline to then run or take a
senior position at a small company you
did the opposite
you went from not just being an officer
in these companies but actually running
the companies - taking a senior position
at Genentech I'd be curious you know we
have one a little bit what your
motivation was but also what have you
seen as the differences between doing
science and development and the small
companies in doing it in order in a
world-class large organization such as
Genentech so the what allowed me really
to make the transition were two things
one is that I had to let go of being the
guy in charge so I've got actually is
for those of you that eventually become
CEOs and for those of you on the panel
who are CEOs and Don you know this
because I was a CEO and a company you
were and you can attach to the job you
get attached to the fact that you're the
guy or you're the gal you're the person
running it it's your story and I was
that way for many decades and in order
to go from there to position where I
wasn't the person in charge the biggest
thing I had to do was actually let go of
that I had to let go of being the guy in
charge and get really comfortable with
being a person on a team but not being
the person who was running it that was
number one and I think made the reason
many CEOs don't end up doing what I did
is because they can't let go number two
is that I was interested in what it
would be like to move into an
environment that had a what looked to me
like infinite financial container in
terms of the size and the amount of
capital it had so I was spending about
30 percent of my time as CEO of Saito
connects a publicly traded biotech
company servicing Wall Street servicing
fund managers and servicing other
investors and I know that this was it
was a big and important part of my job
but it was a consuming part of my job
fascinating and seductive at the
beginning and got a little bit tiresome
at the end and I was yearning for
something that would connect me more
into the signs and medicine of what the
actual business was and so when I got a
call to run business development at
Genentech that seemed like a natural
choice it was one of those calls you get
where you just immediately just say yes
I'll take the job and it's literally a
5-second just
thought so it was it was it was the the
run to a company where I didn't have to
worry about fundraising and and and I
could think about bringing science and
medicine in in a in a place where they
the Hubble sphere if you want was
infinitely large and another and the
other one was letting go of being the
person in charge now what is different
about being drug discovery and
development of Genentech versus that at
a biotech company again relates
primarily to the size and amount of
money we have right now biotech
companies in the therapeutics areas can
are limited by the amount of money they
can raise it's limited to whatever sixty
seventy eighty million dollars maybe at
the most when I was running Sutter
kinetics we could raise hundreds of
millions of dollars even before the
public offering and then another hundred
at the public offering for innovative
ideas the size of the financial
container has to be larger than for non
innovative ideas because you don't
really know what path you have to go
down therapeutically and so now you have
companies that want to be innovative but
have a smaller container they can't take
things through into the into the clinic
as effectively as they could five or six
or ten years ago and as a result they
have to partner well guess who they have
to partner with they have to partner
with us and so moving into the role on
the partnership side where I knew what
these guys were going through and I
could actually solve a lot of their
economic problems while at the same time
developing a positive partnering
relationship struck me is a wonderful
place to go and I think that's been the
biggest difference it's been literally
that we have the money to actually do a
proper development plan around these
products and not cut corners maybe just
following that up maybe you talk a
little bit about what you're trying to
accomplish in your current role and what
do you see as the main opportunities for
Genentech over the next five years on
the scientific side Genentech is now
owned by a large Swiss company that you
may have heard of called Roche so they
acquired us although many people in
Basel feel it was the other way around
and at least culturally we've had a
major impact on Roche the job of
business development at Genentech in the
past and that continues to the present
time has been solely to bring the best
science into Genentech we have one of
the best research and and I would argue
the best development organization in the
industry especially in the area of
cancer and my goal is to scour the world
for great scientific idea
and bring them into Genentech it turns
out that those great scientific ideas
are almost all preclinical because as I
said companies don't have the financial
ability to bring things forward into the
clinic so most of the partnerships we do
we did 20 partnerships last year my
first year there all of them were
preclinical and they were all
preclinical that's where the best
science was so my role at Genentech is
to bring the best science in Jinja in
tech and the future what I'm really
excited about and what I think is is
going to turn out to be the real reason
why the acquisition or merging whatever
you want to call it of these two
companies is gonna turn out to be a
positive is the combination of
innovative therapeutics that attack
disease mechanisms combined with
companion diagnostics to predict who's
going to respond to those medicines in
fact it is one of the only ways we have
to dramatically increase the
productivity of R&D and change our
healthcare industry we have to move from
drugs at work in 4050 percent of the
patients to drugs at work in 80 90
percent of the patients and the only way
we can do that at least in the next
hundred years in my opinion is to decide
who's going to respond to the drug and
Genentech started that with Herceptin
but it's now gonna become a clear part
of almost everything we do sure David
and ball are glad to hear you say that
last question is Genentech you know over
the court you know the course of the
time I've been in the industry has been
without doubt the most successful
innovative company the best science the
you know has really pushed frontiers in
many ways it's been really the place
great scientists wanted to wanted to go
to what is roche done to preserve that
culture really to reserve the secret
sauce that made Genentech so successful
so when roche acquired us they
specifically set Genentech aside as a
separate unit and they called it G red
which is an acronym that stands for
Genentech research and early development
and what it means is the 2,000
scientists and clinicians that were
Genentech Sardi engine are now set aside
and fundamentally bubble-wrapped and
when I say bubble-wrap meaning we have
our own governance we have our own
budget and we don't actually are our
reporting relationship into Roche is
write to the CEO we don't report into an
R&D unit within Basel I don't report
into a business development unit with
Basel we were poured into one person who
heads up gee red Richard Scheller was a
former Stanford professor and Richard
reports directly to Severn Sean who's
the CEO of Roche and so what Roach did
very cleverly unlike say Pfizer when
they would have come to acquire a
company what they would do would be to
shut down the company and ask everyone
to move to Groton Roche didn't say we're
gonna shut down South San Francisco
everyone everyone moved to Basel or
Nutley what they did is said we're gonna
bubble-wrap you we want you to keep
doing what you're doing and they give us
full governance as well as financial
capability to do that so within G red
things haven't changed a whole lot
well except our cost of capital has gone
down we are connected to the largest
diagnostics company in the world and we
have a more stable financial base so I
think those are all positives great well
thanks James
I'd like to move on to David David is a
CEO as I mentioned if cardio DX which is
a pioneering company in the genomics
Diagnostics field focused on the
cardiovascular field unlike James David
came up through the business side as I
learned earlier David's under you know
is a Stanford MBA cloud somewhere in the
80s somewhere in the eighties someone
before that was a economic and computer
science major and now is running you
know one of the really premier most you
know interesting companies in the know
in the life sciences feels you know
you're kind of doing what a lot of the
NBA's I teach wanted you it's like they
don't have a technical background and
they come to me and say I really want to
run a really exciting hot early-stage
company in the life sciences field so
they didn't talk a little bit about your
path and what advice you'd have for
people who want to emulate that if they
should yeah so take everything that
James said about his background and
think the opposite and then you got me
so I think the last biology class I took
was somewhere early in the high school
days and and you know actually grew up
here and thought I'd be involved in
technology firms that was sort of my
love and my passion business school at
Stanford and coming out of that program
I got a an offer to be the first
employee at a company that another
former GSB or a couple years before me
were starting in the oncology space and
I was flattered to get the offer
he and I know a little bit and I said
thanks but no thanks I know I couldn't
even spell oncology I knew it was
related to cancer but could even spell
oncology and so I went off and spent a
couple years in them in the venture
business all in the IT side but the guy
that wanted to hire me was a persistent
guy and the business model that he had
started with didn't really work out so
he had sort of changed a couple of times
and you know he called me two years
later and said now we got a different
business model in this something that
you know I really think you should do
and what I had been trying to do in
those two years post business school was
find the right portfolio company to jump
into that's why I went to the venture
business not because I wanted to you
know be a venture capitalist but because
I thought that was the right forum for
figuring out and taking a long interview
process to say ok this is a company that
I want to jump into and I did I just
didn't happen to jump into one either in
the IT space or in the portfolio the
venture firm I was working with and so I
came into this with my eyes you know
wide open but not this pair of glasses I
needed to have I'd say and and I started
as the fourth employee at this company
and it was senator serendipity at some
point which was I was there to sort of
launch a new business unit and good
fortune shone down upon us and this
business unit went from zero to a
billion dollars in six years
we're number four in the Inc 500 list of
fastest growing companies you know it
was an oncology space we were
distributing products to medical
oncologist with delivering chemo so I'd
like to take a lot of credit for my
career path and deliberateness and all
the kind of things complete serendipity
my philosophy had been if you associate
yourself with really good smart people
good things will happen to you and in
this case it did and I sort of leverage
that into you know at least passing some
what for you know having known something
about the healthcare business and have
done then a three other company since
then but talk a little bit about your
current one cardio DX what's the mission
of the company what's the product what's
the status sure let me leverage off
something that James said I'd like him
fundamentally believe that the only way
we're going to improve our healthcare
system dramatically in the next 100 or
50 years is to spend our current dollars
more effectively and more efficiently
and the trajectory I had on from a
career path I did intersperse a couple
of
venture rules so I've actually gone back
and forth through any operating rules
and venture rules and I spent three
years at TPG before I started car dealer
DX and as I was sitting in the meetings
at TPG when entrepreneurs were coming to
present particularly on the diagnostic
side I would only ask one question there
was always the same question
what's her doctor gonna do differently
with this piece of information than they
can do today and some of the great
science most of which that went right
over my head you know the the the guys
that were presented an entrepreneur said
well not much but it's really cool sign
it says really and I talk to myself
something's wrong with this picture we
have all of this incredible new
technology that allows us to look at
biology in a different way and that
technology is really driven by the
mapping of the human genome and all of
the technologies that spun off of that
and I said something's wrong with this
picture we've got a better flashlight
than we've ever had before we're not
using it appropriately and car-deer DX
was really started in that vein and we
looked at a lot of different therapeutic
area so we approach this from as
non-technical aside as you can get I
said what are the biggest markets where
the variability of care is so huge that
even small improvements in Diagnostics
can have a big impact on patient care
cardiology was was clearly at the top of
that list
and we interviewed 1,100 physicians to
find out what their key challenges were
in the delivery of care and we wrote the
products back and then we went to the
scientist and said can you make a
product that meets this need and so we
came at this from a very different
standpoint it seems like totally obvious
to me that having better information to
make treatment decisions is you know
that's sort of the future I mean that's
what James said said why you don't see
very many companies yet that have been
really successful in the space there's
you know
genomic health it took a long time to
build a business and they've heard in
the oncology space but you haven't seen
you know I would have thought there sort
of be a flood of companies in this area
yeah I think there have been a number of
roadblocks that have an arc still in our
way one is just inertia you know one of
the other companies that I started and
sold was in the handheld prescribing
space we write over three billion
prescript
by hand in this country and given the
technology we have you think that's
probably not the right thing to do and
so we developed a a handheld device to
write a prescription and I use that
example because basically when you were
going in to sell that to a clinician to
say you should use this device it is
better for patient care better
information for you and will reduce the
number of times we kill patients by
giving them the wrong script you know
basically what you're telling the
physician is what you've done the last
30 years is substandard they don't get
often the fact that this is new
technology so don't don't beat yourself
up for last 30 years but same things
happen with Cardiacs we go in and tell
the physician that this genomic test is
often better than the imaging
technologies they have and what they
hear is I'm not practicing the best
medicine and so there is a reluctance at
that point that's number one number two
the FDA rightly or wrongly has stayed
out of the diagnostic space and yet are
fully engaged in the therapeutic and the
device space so when you come to a with
a therapy with a diagnostic and they say
is it fda-approved and you say no it
doesn't need to be all they hear is no
and so then there's a question of what's
the clinic utility and so there's lots
of papers we have to write and those
kinds of things and the third piece is
really on the reimbursement side and
that's true of most healthcare even more
so the Diagnostics base we could be
selling my estimate is ten times more
tests than we are today selling the IE
the physicians are ordering it but I
don't want to do that because the payers
aren't yet on board to pay for the tests
so in terms of a capital need the James
talking about every time I run the test
and it doesn't get paid for B's
insurance company says thanks but no
thanks you know that's a cost that we
bear and so there is a big financial
incentive to limit adoption until you
get the reimbursement piece done yep
once those problems get addressed and
maybe they'll take a while to do that
talk a little bit about the business
model it's the business model here seems
really attract attractive because the
development cost is far less than the
therapeutic the odds of success are far
higher but you get similar sort of a
lifecycle length and you can charge a
good amount for yeah it's one of the
things that really attracted me to the
whole new molecular diagnostics base
just to give you a sense it was exactly
two years from the day
we enrolled our first patient in a our
prospective trial which is really the
key cloning trial the time we're on the
market so two years versus ten twenty
years so you can do it in a much shorter
space it's not cheap you know we spent
almost forty to five million dollars to
get product one to market that counts
the cul-de-sacs and dead ends we went
down but but you know it's not it's not
very it's not particularly cheap and the
business model is if you can provide
better care to the clinicians and be
cost effective for the payers this
should be adopted broadly in the
industry now what has adopted mean does
that mean you had to be on everybody's
guidelines just means you've got lots of
users you know any one of those things
would qualify and the upside is is huge
genomic health is has proven that they
can be they can really change the
standard of care in in breast cancer
great thanks David welcome move on to
Bala hair balm onion is one of the most
prolific and successful inventors in the
life sciences fields around imaging
optics and diagnostics he's been the
founder or driving force behind a hat
more than a half dozen companies maybe
even more I probably couldn't count them
all and holds more than 30 patents and I
can safely say Bala is the only person
at this conference who has won an
Academy Award
yeah which which he won for a in digital
advances in digital cinematography his
latest venture is really tricks and I
want to come back to that because I
think REO metrics is very interesting
both from the technology side but
frankly from the business model in the
innovation side as well but before
getting in Rio metrics eyes wondering if
you just might talk a little bit about
you know one or two of the other
ventures you've been involved in and
sort of the impact that that's had in
the medical field I guess I could start
with you know my entry into the whole
area of Life Sciences was an accidental
event as talking about both of them
saying you know one coming from the
medical side from the business side
whereas in in my case I had nothing to
do with you know I in some of the talks
I give my life is one of contradictions
and I started out and I aspired to be
academician and joined the faculty at
the University of Rochester and then
fell a victim to the exuberance of
materialistic affluence and left the
academic world and came to Silicon
Valley in 1975 so basically I was I
started working on writing images on the
film and I've done quite a bit of work
in that area and accidentally I found
out that there was an unmet need in the
area of medical imaging of taking
digital data and writing it on the film
that's how I got into medical imaging
and so I helped develop the first
generation of laser film recorders for
medical imaging and that has
fundamentally changed the way in which
the images are being presented to a
radiologist and taking the depth of
information that is generated in the
computer and presented today you can't
find any other technology every every
image that you see in any digital
modality whether it's a CT MRI or any of
that and I could say hey you know I had
a role to defining that 30 years ago I
wonder if you can talk a little bit
about real metrics I mean I know a
little bit about the company and its
really fascinating on multiple
dimensions a little bit of the original
concept of real metrics what products
you're developing and talk up a little
bit about the innovation model within
the company as well um you know one of
the advantages that I have is that I've
been in Silicon Valley since 1975 and
what motivated me to think out and
actually think in terms of going to
India is that I looked at everybody
looking at developing part of the world
in either they had an approach to
looking at it from a charitable point of
view social entrepreneurial things of
that nature or a cost arbitrage model or
what can I go and save money get
things dying over there you know David
Kelly of design school from Stanford
I've known him for a long time and that
one statement that he had made that
probably had more impact on me is
innovation starts at how you frame the
problem so I looked around and I said
you know I started my first company with
350 thousand dollar investment this is
in 1980 today that pays two weeks worth
of payroll maybe when you start a
company and that's just not sufficient
and that it really the opportunity
exists in India to be able to do what I
did 30 years ago so the question really
is what can you do there you cannot do
any more here and then combine that with
the statement that David Kelly did is
let's define the problem a frame the
problem in terms of how do you solve
develop technology to address the bottom
of the pyramid and then by definition if
you have the cost economics worked out
then you have a solution that's not just
for at the bottom of the pyramid but for
the rest of the pyramid as well so that
was the motivation but which REO metrics
have got started and it has been a
really a fascinating experience because
defining the problem from the developing
war point of view as opened up
innovation opportunities that would have
never been possible if I had done the
same thing here in Silicon Valley one of
the things that's interesting about Rio
metrics is you have a foot in San Carlos
in Silicon Valley and another even
bigger footprint in in Bangalore talk a
little bit about the cultural
differences between innovation in
Silicon Valley and the types of people
who do here and managing innovation in
India yeah I would say that probably
this is the most difficult challenge on
your face I would say that as much I
felt that because I have been successful
in silicon
only that I ought to be able to take
what I learned here and translate that
to India that was the most unmitigated
disaster that I ever encountered because
the tendency in the eastern part of the
world is not just India I think this is
true of Asia I was in Singapore on
Monday running a workshop over there the
tendency to want to own the task rather
than own the problem and that if you
really are talking about innovation you
have to own the problem and second thing
is failure is inherent in the process of
exploration I continually tell the
people if you're afraid of heights
you'll never be a mountain climber and
the concept of facing and accepting
failure is amazingly absent in that part
of the world because the competitive
nature of their upbringing and etc even
the society they don't want to face
failure and without carrying through
that barrier to being a real problem
so while it has been very cost effective
to try different things in that part of
the world the innovation spirit has been
lacking because of the inability to face
value one last question and this is
around assuming real metrics is
successful in developing the diagnostic
box that you that you're working on now
what do you see as the barriers to
adoption in India and particularly
around how medicine is practiced
differently in India than it is in the
developed world and and in fact it's
been a really fascinating understanding
in you know in in the West that people
going to medicine go to medicine after
an undergraduate degree and quite a bit
of scientific training and so on whereas
in the British system people actually go
right out of high school and their
undergraduate program itself is into
medicine so what you find is that what
you assume in this part of the world in
terms of how medicine is
practice is very different from the
medicine practice over there they are
much more clinicians than quantitative
medicine focused and therefore trying to
whatever the solutions that you're going
to provide and to put it in the context
that in which they practice medicine and
and you know I have a way of saying that
you have to think like a biologist and
act like a biologist okay in a way that
you you serve their unmet needs and the
same thing applies to medicine in that
part of the world
great thank you Don we have you back
clean up here is Don Joseph is the chief
operating officer for bio ventures for
Global Health which is a nonprofit that
has the audacious mission of trying to
create basically the environment and
incentive system to get biotech
pharmaceutical diagnostics companies to
develop drugs for unmet and underserved
global health conditions and it was
interesting just thinking through look
the backgrounds we have James from
medicine and science we have David who
came up through business Bala
kind of through optics and science and
Don through law I think we have a lot of
different routes to end up in this
industry and Donna you don't be
interesting if you could talk both the
transition from law you know into the
biotechnology field and then work more
so from going from for-profit and
actually Don worked with James and
worked with a number of other successful
companies in the biotechnology industry
and then going into the nonprofit sphere
and whether you you know both why you
made that transition and whether you
think for people who are considering
going into nonprofit later on if it
makes sense to start off on the
for-profit side sure happy to and I
can't back clean up because these guys
hit it out of the park already I'll take
it from there
my my past is even more sorted because I
have a solid humanities background
before law school so I was literally
inarticulate in the life sciences
through my
but what I I was always interested in it
and wanted to work with it my law
practice had involved it somewhat
peripherally but again not not any great
degree until about ten or twelve years
into my career and what I decided Rob
was that the great thing about being in
a law firm is you touch a lot of
different projects in many different
industries and that's a great thing but
what ultimately I found to be
frustrating was you don't really get
embedded in any in any project you get
in you get and do a deal or provide
advice or a structure or solve a problem
and then they move on and keep doing
what they're doing and you're left to
start over and work again with someone
new there's many parts of that that are
fun but ultimately to me it was
frustrating I wanted to get in and get
my hands dirty and really be a part of
something so I consciously looked out
for an opportunity in the life sciences
again partly through serendipity as as
has been said before I had the chance
knowing sitting in an office in San
Francisco the odds were that life would
take me either toward life science or
technology and my preference was on the
life science side because I saw the
potential for impact this is when
companies like Genentech and Amgen and
others were have making a huge
difference in the world and opening up
all kinds of opportunities and although
again I didn't have the scientific
training I really wanted to be a part of
that so I made the jump roughly 15 years
after my law career began into a
neuroscience company here locally called
afina neurosciences and we worked on the
Alzheimer's disease in epilepsy and MS
and other things and I found it hugely
fulfilling to be able to learn about
that so ongoing learning was fantastic
and also to have to watch these drugs go
through a process get approved and begin
to change people's lives so I was in the
industry side of things for another 15
years or so in initially legal roles and
then beyond into business roles
corporate development business
development operating roles of one type
in another and again I found personally
my it was time for me to try something
new to come at the industry from a
different direction and I was lucky
enough to have the opportunity to do
that initially with a group called one
world health which develops drugs but
for
elected diseases and in that particular
case things like malaria leishmaniasis
and some other things so again I was
challenged by learning something new
seeing the industry in a different way
putting what little skill I had to use
from a different direction and again the
chance to make an impact in a different
way and to challenge myself like oh the
second part your question is sorry just
real quick so having said that I would
say that I my personal advice
generically are in the abstract is it's
far more helpful and be interesting your
James viewpoint on this later but I
think it's far more helpful to get a
functional skill learn it and acquire it
and then you can go out and market
yourself with that skill as opposed to
taking kind of the kumbaya approach I
really want to help what can I do I'm
really excited I'm really motivated now
admittedly the world is different today
than when I did this even a short time
ago much less a long time ago and and I
wouldn't say this is absolute but I do
think that you that anyone interested in
the nonprofit sphere would be
well-served to get a functional skill
and training because just as Brooke
Byers always said a small company is not
a training ground
I can guarantee you the nonprofit world
is not a training camp so you're not
going to get guidance and mentorship
from a functional point of view anywhere
near the depth that you would even in
smaller companies much less larger
companies such as Genentech that can
offer that to you and then translate
that into one you'll know your sphere
better you'll know where you potentially
can make a play have an impact and and
then look into whether nonprofit is
right for you so if you could talk a
little bit about the mission of BV teach
what are you trying to accomplish and
what are the organization's goals sure
what we're what we want to do very
simply is bring the innovation of
biotech to global health and neglected
disease work and if you look at the
numbers over the last 10 years roughly
half of the new drugs approved in the
United States have come from the biotech
side of the
of the industry as opposed to
pharmaceutical companies that number is
only going to go up year over year as
the big pharma pipelines are challenged
and the biotech techniques take hold and
pay off more and more and more so much
of the innovation in drug development
generally is coming from the biotech
sector we think it's far
underrepresented and we know it's far
underrepresented and the global health
sphere and what we're trying to do is to
break down some of the barriers that
keep the biotech sector from having a
greater involvement in global health we
think that innovation comes from two
primary directions you can't innovate
unless you have information unless you
have an incentive and those are the two
things that we try to provide assistance
to biotech companies in assessing
potential opportunities in global health
the information side we have content on
our website we provide information about
neglected diseases through our global
health primer that you can look at both
from a disease point of view and also
from a target or pathway point of view
if you're a biotech company wondering
how you can get involved and incentives
we've worked on things like the Priority
Review voucher which is a very elegant
tool I won't describe it fully but it's
a it's an incentive to a biotech company
to get a drug approved for a neglected
disease because it lets you then shorten
the review time for any other drug that
you have or they and you can sell that
voucher to a third party so information
and incentives for global health aimed
at the biotech sector is what we're all
about how much success have you had yet
because they understand why the large
companies are getting into this because
you know the Mercs the GlaxoSmithKline
x' they have a global reach they see a
big market in emerging markets you know
and they also have for many reasons a PR
reason that they want to get into into
underserved global health the smaller
companies you know I know you're working
on the incentives but how much success
is there been for smaller companies and
what do you think is really going to be
sort of the change that has to happen
there for there to be far more of the
small or more innovative companies
working in the field well it's it's a
real challenge Rob you're right and let
me take a local example to illustrate
the situation a little bit there's a
company up the road called Anna core
Anna core has a specific Kem
boron chemistry platform that they use
to develop drugs with potential
commercial application and a couple of
different areas they have partnerships
with GlaxoSmithKline and they're a very
prototypical recently public initially
venture backed small biotech company but
what they have that many other biotech
companies don't have is a developed
portfolio where their chemistry platform
can be used for neglected diseases so
they have an advanced collaboration in
human African trypanosomiasis hat
sleeping sickness
that's about to bear fruit and pay off
and the way that they've convinced their
board who are a very typical venture
board very keen on return very keen on
resource very keen on the business model
that that they have in front of them the
way that they've convinced their board
is if we can do this on a cost neutral
basis without interfering with our
commercial platform we can then make a
difference in the world in these areas
where it so desperately needed and
they've accomplished that through
partnerships with nonprofit groups such
as DND eye drugs for neglected disease
initiative and gates funding that have
allowed them to reach cost neutrality
and the potential carrot or selling
point to is to say this will this will
help inform our chemistry platform it
will read on our technology and assist
us in the development of our commercial
products okay just one last question how
do you know measuring nonprofit you know
success in a nonprofits always hard
measuring it in some place like you know
be vgh where you're trying to create an
environment rather than doing a specific
product is even harder how does the
organization measure success we don't do
that anymore we just try to have fun
the mache Rob it depends on the program
because for example in the in the
Priority Review voucher setting we
measure success by how many vouchers are
issued and how many have been utilized
and the answer to that one quickly is
one has been issued and it has not yet
been utilized and that tells us that
that program needs more clarity so we're
working on that with the FDA to try to
smooth out some of the speed bumps in
our incentives program which is nascent
you know on the
I'm bored the answer will be if we can
get traction with a sponsor to fund the
development of a point-of-care
diagnostic tool for differential
diagnosis of fever which is what that
incentive is about then that's a huge
success right there and getting
developers to enter a competition to
generate that diagnostic tool will also
be a measure of success but you're right
we deal in ideas we're not a development
company per se we don't have drugs in
our pipeline or Diagnostics to be able
to measure sales or revenues from and it
is challenging but with the advent of
venture philanthropy and some of the
metrics and techniques that are now used
in our sector generally we we think
we're we can track our progress right
thanks I'm gonna open it up to questions
in a few minutes so everybody get ready
this is going to be the audience
participation for portion of the program
in a minute but I just while you're
thinking of your question I want to
prime with one or two questions for the
panel my first question is you know in
the areas that you're working in right
now what are one or two trends that may
not be obvious to the casual observer
but is really going to impact the field
over the next five to ten years well I
can I can actually talk about it I think
having spending the amount of time that
I'm spending both in India and in Africa
fundamentally I would say that a mindset
needs to change in the sense we've
always thought about health care
delivery or health care as a economic
burden and what we are not really
looking at is actually an opportunity to
create economic activity and I think
that the key here is to run the health
care just like the way you would run any
other services that you would do in in
in economics so fundamentally what
really tricks is trying to do is to
first define both affordability and
access and then define what is the
appropriate technology that's going to
allow you to deliver the goods and
services with
that affordability index so if you do it
that way and you also do it in a way
there is a compelling economics at the
local level in terms of value add in
terms of income generation then the
people who make the income generation
have the goods to sell buy the goods and
services you are trying to sell I think
you know the concept of micro financing
applied to healthcare is more or less
going to be the new model 87% of all
healthcare dollars spent in India comes
out of individuals pockets so you don't
focus on what the third-party
reimbursement is you really think about
what is the discretionary expenditure
that they can have and then you develop
the technology to work within those
economic constraints I think this
approach what real metrics is doing is I
think it's going to if we are successful
in breaking through all the barriers
that we see I think it will be a
different way to do that if you can do a
Diagnostics for less than ten dollars
who cares where who what the
reimbursement is and the idea is the
technology is there to be able to
deliver that today I guess I was gonna
say I think there's an economic squeeze
play that's gonna happen within the
healthcare industry because of two
trends that you're all very much aware
of and that's aging and obesity these
are by far the most important trends
that are going to affect not only within
the developed world but also within the
developing world as well and the reason
that these particular trends are
particularly potent is because they're
both post evolutionary and that is that
our own mechanisms for fighting disease
don't work very well because we weren't
designed to have 40 percent body fat and
we weren't designed to live longer than
25 or 35 years and yet both things are
occurring in rampant increase in our
society and so because of that the
medicines have to actually enter into a
biology that had never had to enter into
before so this combined with the fact
that both these trends take people out
of the workforce which reduces the GDP
if you want of the country generates the
squeeze play because the amount of money
a society is willing to spend on health
care as a percentage of GDP has to go up
with those two trends and if the amount
of money it's willing to spend
as a percent of GDP is capped by some
reasonable economic number and all that
means is that pricing power is gonna go
down for the pharmaceutical industry and
for healthcare in general which comes
back to they think the issues that both
Bal and David and I were talking about
which is efficiency or effectiveness
turns out to be far more important than
the actual cost in the actual cost you
have to be able to show that what you do
truly makes a difference for patients in
the past you could get by with minimal
benefits but I think what you're gonna
find over the next five to ten years is
that's gonna be replaced by having to
have drugs and diagnostics that
dramatically change the way patients are
managed we're starting to see this at
the FDA now and this is the part they
may not be aware of is for the first
time in the last year for the first time
the CMS guys they're involved in pricing
are sitting in with the FDA guys on
Product Approval now they came to those
meetings under a part of the
governmental regulation which allows
them to see non approved drugs quote in
order to get the ball rolling for
eventual CMS approval but I think we
should all be aware the reason they're
there is because one of the biggest
toxicities we're gonna see if droughts
going forward is price we're seeing this
at Genentech with Avastin where there's
a lot of pressure on the company with
regards to how much it charges for his
drug but this is gonna be true for every
pharmaceutical and biotech company and I
think that the companies that can face
this head-on by being more efficient in
terms of the way they develop drugs and
more efficient in the way they spend
money are the ones that have entually
win I want to add one comment and in the
comment that you made in the United
States today there are 65,000 people 400
years or older the oldest person died at
the age of 114 four weeks ago and those
people retired between the age of 58 to
62 I don't think they ever thought that
they were gonna live long that long no
so to a large extent we may need to
change the shift of focus in managing
patients instead of focusing on illness
how do you maintain wellness well I
think that you know I always say if I
was thirty years younger I would focus
on how do you use technology
have people actively engage in
productive contribution to society
because all of us have to do that for a
long period of time than we had
originally we're fixator not fascinating
we're fixated on 65 roughly as the
retirement age and when that was put in
place in Germany and the mid 1800s the
average lifespan was four years we only
did four years back in retirement now as
you point out the average lifespan is
20-30 years and is only getting longer
and longer and so can a country really
afford to have that many retired people
or people not productively contributing
to the GDP I don't think so I think we
have to go back in some ways the way it
was even before that where people just
continued to work and the idea of
retirement at 65 it just is an idea that
it can't be afforded these days I'd like
to mention a trend that I see coming
from another direction and maybe this is
a little bit of a wishful thought but
along with globalization and the
integration of world markets and and the
emerging power of the BRIC countries and
others comes a desire on the part of
those countries to make lives better for
their own people and I think that means
addressing neglected diseases which
affect billions worldwide last year
total global health spending on
neglected diseases was about 3.2 billion
dollars Pfizer alone spent more than
double that and their R&D they're simply
and that's not at all a criticism Pfizer
that's simply to say that not nearly
enough money is being spent on neglected
disease research and it's been too easy
to ignore that segment of the population
and of the world but again as
integration happens as boundaries blur
as travel increases and as markets
become more attractive even to the to
the US and European based and Japanese
companies they will have an incentive to
be more interested in solving those
local problems in in those countries
they'll be more affected by it they'll
have more at stake and there'll be more
of a reason and again I hope that's true
let me add two comments one is
leveraging off of something that James
said for the non MD PhDs in the audience
what he what he said in the beginning
I've known it for a long time translate
is for obesity and diabetes Darwin
doesn't matter video we get those
disease after we've had children and so
natural selection doesn't work in terms
of weaning out we
much more elegant so we have a
fundamentally different medical problem
than we've ever had before and the only
other comment I'd make is I think
particularly to the US healthcare system
one of the fundamental changes is we're
gonna have to figure out who are the
gatekeepers to our health care we can't
continue to spend at the rate that we're
spending on just it doesn't work it
blows up very quickly is it the primary
care physician that is the gatekeeper is
it the specialist who knows that I'd had
treat that disease or is it the payer
and today it's a combination and a very
awkward combination of all three of
those and I think one of the things we
need to do as a society
it's figuring out where are we gonna
make those decisions do we go to the
English system where you know a
governmental body makes some of those
decisions where you can afford to spend
or do we let it happen in the free
market system and I think it's gonna be
a very fascinating thing to watch over
the next 10 years you know one of the
comments that I want to make is that
often you think of the developing world
at the bottom of the pyramid and you
think about it only from a technology
innovation point of view it is also an
opportunity to create new economic
models for example you can't go in and
talk about an incentive based healthcare
delivery in this world I mean I would be
driven out of any discussions at any
point whereas because so much of
healthcare delivery comes out of pocket
you can begin to think in terms of
incentive based mechanisms with regard
to the cost of healthcare that they get
and one of the approaches were looking
at in India is India tremendously
there's a cost
the idea of savings it's so prevalent
and you know India saves the savings
rate is north of 20 percent so the idea
is instead of similar to credit card
score can you think in terms of a
wellness score that the wellness core
actually impacts the amount of savings
that they get because you simply
arbitrage seeing the long term interest
rates which is short-term interest rate
when somebody has a very high wellness
score then it's a long-term deposit into
their medical savings account so
essentially
use diagnostics as a way of assessing
the risk arbitrage and on an actuarial
basis how somebody manages this and from
a banking point of view from an
insurance point of view this is a
well-established practice but those
kinds of concepts cannot be applied in
the healthcare context and a place like
the developing world may actually be
wonderful
incubation areas to try these different
business models and once we they work
over there we can bring that back over
here they can teach us it's a very
interesting idea it'd be interesting to
see if it develops where Diagnostics for
prevention become more prevalent there
whereas here the Diagnostics are really
more for treatment decisions yeah and in
fact I think I'll go one step further
than that and but I talked about
managing old age and I would say today
we have the technology by which we can
actually proactively warn a person
living by themselves saying something
the way in which they they walk the way
their face looks when they go shaver in
front of a mirror you can actually be
proactive in saying from a preventive
point of view rather than waiting for
the clinical symptoms to develop I think
we need to take a different approach to
maintenance of wellness rather than just
focusing on illness and I think
technology's gonna have a role to play
there you know it's a simple equation of
calories in versus calories out and I've
got a tool that tells me every text my
children send to me every day but I
don't have a tool that says how many
calories do I burn by walking around and
exercising and running the dog and what
I ate and if those tools are closed and
not quite here yet but you know I look
at the menus and say this is 600
calories or seven I mean if you have the
data I fundamentally believe you will
change their behavior we don't have
David today and I think that's where
technology will help us then there is a
program in Stanford called stepped up
stochastic with Accenture mmm-hmm that
they have a program in which that you
actually get a pedometer and then
depending on how many steps you take you
are a platinum gold or so on and then
the point you win
are actually used to play a game in
which you win dollars so there's a
fantastic program I think comes out of
the computer science program and so I
think the tools are there you're going
to do that so I have to put a pitch in
here for a company I'm on the board of
called hope lab which has just spun out
a company called Sam Z which is doing
exactly the thing it same things AM Z as
a pedometer that you give to kids and if
the kids run around they get points
within the pedometer which I download
the computer and allows them to go the
further levels on a game so this is not
money these are kids so what their
instant doing is going to the next level
it's kind of like farmville but in order
to get further on you have to walk
around and they did a clinical trial
with with children between the ages of 8
and 14 all of them obese all in with BMI
over 30 so these are these are
reasonably obese kids they all increase
their amount of walking or running to
the equivalent of one Marathon per month
based on Sam Z and they loved it and so
here's the device to go back to what
David's saying and you're mentioning
with Stanford and it's a simple device I
mean these things are in every iPhone
that allows you to measure that and
people are changing their behavior I
think in some ways that's going to do
more for health than any type of
medication we can come up with for
obesity or as an exercise mimetic
pharmaceutical professor chess thank you
thank you for your comments which come
from I guess a lot of experience and
looking at it from the other end of the
tunnel I think there are some of us here
who are this end of the tunnel thinking
of starting enterprises building a
company and I have a particular question
in the diagnostic sphere and we had a
speaker early on from Proteus I think
who talked about making medicine
available to all and some of us we're
trying to do that in cancer diagnostic
and we want to deal with data patient
data and we have a choice to make at
this stage as to whether we go in and
try and seek cooperations with
established big medical device companies
who have very proprietary about the data
they keep or build something ourselves
and take the risk that it will not be
adopted that their layers and layers of
purchases within the system we'll have
to persuade to get it adopted and as a
starting company as a as an asset
company how do you think about this I
mean do you really bite the bullet and
go down partnerships with the Gees and
the Siemens of this world or do you
stick it out and try and create
something that you think is really good
and take the risk that it will never be
adopted and probably David and James you
may have thought about this in your
views everybody's to have something to
do on this one I can I can chime in you
know data and the clinical samples that
you use which is the raw materials the
development of a diagnostic are
absolutely the most important decision
you'll probably make in the life of the
company and our philosophy has been go
out and find if those samples with the
clinical data already exists but be
prepared for the chance that it's very
unlikely that they will be in exactly
the same form you want with all the
clinical data so there's a hybrid
approach that we took which I think at
least worked for us which is we went and
found a couple of small courts of
patients that gave us some early looks
at the science and the data to see
whether directionally we were correct
but once we got that proof of concept to
some extent we had to do it all
ourselves because we could never collect
exactly the right patients with all the
right clinical data and the samples
handled properly and even if all of that
existed in a large Pharma or medical
device company as you pointed out their
reluctance to share it with you is very
very high and so I think I think you
should try going down that path because
it's a lot cheaper but I think you
should prepare with a back-up plan for
doing it yourself because the the chance
of success there is gonna be low I think
you know since I beat down this pot over
the last 35 years and six companies each
one of them went to a certain point and
I believe in evolution in the sense
either you be eaten or you eat so in
fortunately in all the companies that I
started it they went public and then be
eaten or they were eaten before they
went public so
to a large extent I really believe that
in in the space that you're really
talking about to two points that I want
to make one is we always think in terms
of the data has to come from here
biggest revelation that I had was in the
last company before real metrics that I
did in Silicon Valley it took me six
months to collect data on cd4 counts on
HIV patients it takes me two weeks in
India to collect the same amount of data
so and the cost of collecting data data
is very different so I think oftentimes
we do Ken Mehlman used to be the Dean at
the School of Medicine here used to say
you look for lost key under the the
light in so true in medicine we tend to
be operating where we are already have
information sometimes putting yourself
into a different situations opens up
opportunities so I think in trying to
address the question that you ask I
would say that maybe the pathways that
we have followed in the last three
decades may not be the pathway that's
gonna work for the next decade and we
need to think out of the box of how do
we go about doing this that one comment
to make I think that within I can speak
to the therapeutic area it's really
clear that the most the most common way
companies and therapeutic areas fail is
because the drugs don't work
it's attrition 9% of molecules that
start into development make it onto the
market that's a remarkably low number
and so everything that one does as a CEO
of a companies in therapeutics should be
to increase that probability if you can
raise enough money that you can do
proper clinical development with
companion diagnostics I would recommend
companies do it on their own and partner
as late as possible it gives you control
you maximize the value it's your baby on
the other hand these days you can't do
that and so forming partnerships early
on is the only way not to erode that
probability of success because if you
start cutting corners in discovery and
in development
guarantee you the probability is going
to look down and if it starts going down
any further than that nine percent
you've got a business that just by by
just by dint of statistics is very
unlikely to work so kind of a
non-traditional point of view on this
would be and maybe I didn't understand
the question fully but I think the first
question to ask yourself is what do you
want to do because if you're out to make
money then everything that's been said
is exactly right and even if you're not
out to make money of what's been said is
right because you do you do have to
validate it is if you think about PLoS
for example is an open source literature
kind of resource so the basic question
is do you want to make make revenue or
not if at some point you don't care
about that or your backers don't care
about that then you might explore
different kinds of models so there's a
company called Napo pharmaceuticals for
example and they're a little bit of a
hybrid they're developing a drug for
AIDS related diarrhea and the way that
they went about their partnering program
they definitely have partners and they
definitely are for-profit entity but
they signed up their global health
partners first in China and and in India
and then they found their commercial
partner for US and Europe now that is
definitely an upstream approach but it
was an approach that the board was
willing to back because they felt that
the global health need was so great and
that was actually their their priority
so there might be more than one way of
thinking about it from a model point of
view but certainly any sort of revenue
driven exit strategy type of model
involves everything that's been said but
if you if you're a little more open to a
non revenue or exit you might consider
some of these other ideas thank you for
joining us at the conference today I
wanted to ask given how hard it is to
get drugs approved and part of the
reason is navigating the FDA and some of
the regulatory approval processes do you
think the u.s. is bound to lose its
leadership position in medical
innovation and what I mean is in
developing game-changing innovative
therapies that are often
most expensive to develop and if so what
do you think what do you propose a
solutions to prevent this loss of
leadership sometimes that question no is
the answer we're we're not going to lose
our leadership position in fact most of
the pharmaceutical companies are placing
their research in developing units in
the United States from other countries
because of the clarity that they have
that the best science is going on right
now is in the United States by a
longshot
now I think that both China and India
are are ramping up butting in terms of
true innovative science that has
generated medicines they are way behind
us and I think we should make that clear
to your question about the FDA the
probability that a drug gets approved by
the FDA once a new drug application as
being has been put in front of them is
about 80 percent right now so there's a
lot of crinkled paper and a lot of
crinkled psyches around the FDA in our
industry and I think that it's time that
we combine our discussion with the FDA
with some inward-looking about what kind
of drugs were making and in fact the
best way to get a drug approved in the
FDA is to give them data that either
increases survival or or decrease it
increases survival or increases the
quality of life of a patient and with
the disease if you do that the FDA will
approve your drug they're not likely to
not approve it at this point because of
price subtly but the discussion becomes
one of what is the amount of benefit
that they're willing to pay for and that
I think is going to be is going to
continue to be a discussion with them
but I think the main issue in our
industry and most of the failures that
occur occur for scientific reasons
before we able to get to the FDA and the
reason for that is because we don't
understand enough biology frankly and
the more biology we understand and the
better we are about being able to use
our biological understanding with
Diagnostics to choose who responds to a
drug the better drug is going to be put
in front of the FDA I think the FDA is
gonna do what has always been it's done
since its inception in the 1930s and
it's gonna swing with political
pressures one way or the other and there
are things that does that I don't agree
with there and I can give you some
specific examples if you wish but on the
other hand I think the the larger lever
we can pull is actually building better
but James did the political borders
matter anymore Genentech being a great
example I think 13 straight phase 3
trials that succeeded and worked you
know South Karen Sisco based owned by a
Swiss company I mean does does it matter
where your domicile anymore it doesn't
matter where your domicile what matters
is where the scientists are and so my
point the United States is gonna play
this important role in research and
development is because most of the good
research and development in the
pharmaceutical sector is occurring
within the boundaries of this country
Novartis has decided to move all of its
research to Boston has very little left
in Basel although it's a basel based
company Roche has decided to to focus
its energies in research and development
in California and in Basel as well as
putting in a major effort in Shanghai
but frankly in comparison what we're
doing here it's a it's a drop in the
bucket you know James to support what
you said I would actually put the
biggest source is not the pharmaceutical
companies setting up that research
facilities it's the 20 to 30 billion
dollar and ih1 absolutely because that's
where the senior corn comes from yeah
and there is no other country can
compete even remotely closely the
generation of the seed corn that leads
to I mean pharma companies actually
spend more dollars on D not in our and I
think it's very important to recognize
that you know in the rest of the world
the the seed corn comes from already
funding from the government in the
United States whether it's neglected
diseases or advanced diseases or that's
where the source of information is I'm
probably more concerned that Americans
aren't going into science and medicine
as much as they were before
yeah the good news is that the people
who are in the rest of world are coming
here so yeah at least for some time just
need to make it a little easier for them
yes very much so
I wanted to ask a question about
personalized medicine when do you think
we'll see genomic information being
integrated into electronic medical
records and if obviously it's not there
now but when do you think that might
happen and what is it going to take for
that transition to happen where it
becomes actionable for providers I'll
take the first cut I mean
another way to ask the question is one
of you have an electronic medical
records I mean what is the health care
system you know going to generate you
know the kind of efficiencies that the
rest of us do you know in managing our
music you know Palo Alto Medical
Foundation you know middle of Silicon
Valley well-funded
they were late to the game on the
molecular no matter where so I think I
think it's a long way to go but I think
the key question you asked is when is it
actionable and that's why I am
challenged with some of the personalized
medicine models that are more on the
consumer side 23andme and Navigenics
know those folks well I know I should
exercise more I know I should eat better
getting the genetic test isn't going to
change my behavior so I think it all has
to be around the actionable piece and
then that's what sort of what we're
focused on and it's personalized
medicine isn't it you shouldn't think
about as a blockbuster we're not gonna
have everybody do everything
simultaneously it's very much taking
million patient populations and cutting
them down into a hundred or two hundred
thousand patient populations that I will
treat this hundred thousand differently
than this hundred thousand and this
hundred thousand so it's gonna be brick
by brick I think it's gonna be very
evolutionary and not revolutionary
genomic health being one but I think
there's gonna be lots of little niches
that are and we're gonna turn around
someday as a boy
we really are in the age of personalized
medicine even though it never hit us
over the head fast Mike the answer to
your question is I think we having been
part of genomics companies and so on I
think we tend to always think off in a
very narrow sense you know the way that
I think it's important to look at
disease is a process disease is not a
state and that it is important not only
to know whether the process onset has
occurred
but where you are in that process my own
sense is that it is not gonna be just
genomic data it may be proteins it may
be the metabolic parameters that you
have to make measurements at multiple
level to not just look for your
predisposition for getting the disease
or even the onset of the disease but
actually know where you
so the treatment processes that one
would undertake would be very very
different
we the way we look at Diagnostics have
to fundamentally change it has to be
thought of as an instrumentation in a
petrochemical industry you don't just go
and look at the raw material going into
the factory but you have monitoring at
various stages and I think if we take it
from that point of view in my context
the personalized medicine is really
about where are you in the process and
what is the right course of treatment
that with which you're gonna impact that
process let me add to Bhalla statement I
think it's a fundamentally different way
that we think about our healthcare we
tend to think about our healthcare like
we think about our automobile we run it
until something breaks we take it to the
shop they take that part out and they
put in a new one and we run it again
till it breaks that's the way we think
about health care okay you're exactly
right we need to monitor every day how
well is the engine working is one
cylinder not working and that's really
what personalized medicine is it's
monitored out on a very frequent basis
to be able to see the trends and not
wait till something breaks and the only
way that's gonna happen is we get off
the third party reimbursement for
Diagnostics and really make it such a
way that you know when you are actually
monitoring the functioning of the car
you're not asking whether or not your
insurance is gonna pay for it and you do
it because that makes sense for you and
I think that's where the affordability
that is gonna drive the delivery of
healthcare I think the other thing that
so agree with what they've said so
there's gonna be a kind of Diagnostics
it relates to defining your clinical
State or defining your physiological
state which is really what you're
talking about
right there's another part of
diagnostics that's already happening
it's happening both at a protein level
and a genomic level and that is in order
to predict who's gonna get a drug so a
drug that Genentech and roshun working
on frump lexicon which is four million
in melanoma only works if you have a
mutation at residue 600 of a protein
that drives that cancer if you have that
v600e mutation you get the drug and it
does energize some it does dramatic
things for you if you don't have a
mutation it's a useless drunk so in that
sense those tumors are gonna be
genomically quote-unquote characterized
because you're going to be looking at d
in fact I think the future is that
there's gonna be no drug without a test
for it so we're gonna lose our idea of a
therapeutic in the absence of a
diagnostic they're gonna be flip sides
at the same coin
which really changes the way we think
about Diagnostics you think about
Diagnostics now is annealed to a
therapeutic as a different form of
Diagnostics in addition to what you're
talking about which are those
Diagnostics which will allow you to more
effectively monitor the clinical and
physiological State Thanks you guys a
little bit and so I'm wondering how you
plan to address some of the misalignment
with the doctors especially around
Diagnostics you know they'd be seeing
patients less and possibly having less
revenue from imaging and and whatnot
that one's sort of pointed at me so I'll
take it further
so it's a it's a fascinating question we
provide a test the clinicians the way
they don't make any money on so they
don't get any fee for either ordering
the tests or interpreting the tests so
it's like prescribing a drug for them
and yet we are competing against a
technology and a process and a procedure
imaging that they do make money on so
you can imagine that our sales and
marketing focus is different for those
folks that make money on imaging and
those that don't
it's interesting the first customer we
had was a guy that runs at a very large
Imaging Center in Phoenix and the reason
he was our first and in some respects
our best customer is he understands the
limitations of imaging so what we're
trying to do is and it gets back to the
personalized medicine question genomic
and genetic information shouldn't be
treated any differently than everything
else you know about this patient and so
I think about this as all of these
things need to go into the combined
knowledge of that physician has for that
patient and what all we're saying is
there are lots of times when imaging may
not be the right first step or second
step use something else first and we've
got to convince the physician that
that's better patient care and I
fundamental it's better patient care
they will put their economics aside that
may be naive what what if eventually we
started paying for
performance I mean I think that in the
end they're whizzes eventually gonna go
to a situation and there's gonna be I'm
a big believer this should be true for
pharmaceuticals as well if the drug
works you pay us if it doesn't you don't
now you have to get really confident
about your drugs in order to do that and
as a physician you'd have to get really
confident about your ability to perform
care but if you really want to align
incentives have the physicians get paid
for how well their patients do I get an
example of that that I've talked about
in the device world particularly in
these implantable defibrillators
beautiful elegant faces but we don't
know who to put them in and they only
fire in about 20 to 25 percent of the
patient we put them in I was talking to
the senior folks at Medtronic and
guidance in Boston and they're all
trying to eke out another half a percent
market share because the devices are all
essentially the same and I said I can
tell you how to get a hundred percent
market share tomorrow and they obviously
didn't believe me and I said here James
it don't be paid go to CMS and say don't
pay me when the device is put in pay me
one in five hours and you will have a
hundred percent market share tomorrow
yeah they didn't take me up on that way
eventually thing that's gonna have to
happen by the way I think economically
we don't have any choice eventually it's
gonna have to align that way and this
goes back to the issue about preventive
medicine about exercise etc an
electronic medical records so that we
can define what success is you know the
I would say that another fundamental
change in our philosophy have to changes
somehow we're willing to assign your
probability with regard to the way we
cross the street
when it comes to medicine we want to be
deterministic and in fact if you
actually look at the way medicine got
practiced 450 years ago
physicians made the decision based on
observation the error bar was very large
and the role of Diagnostics was to
continue to provide information to
minimize that error bar to assume that
we're gonna eliminate that error bar if
you believe that I want a piece of
Golden Gate Bridge because I think we
are in a mindset we think in terms of
everything to be a hundred percent
certain in fact the FDA problem is
really about not understanding
biostatistics you know in clinical
trials when you actually think about it
30 percent is pretty simple effect in
in India the placebo of affect is
greater than 50% so you're really
talking about affecting a small
percentage of people one way or the
other and even in Manatee in Diagnostics
we need to be cognizant of the fact that
what we are providing the information or
providing is we're increasing the
probability that the decision being made
is the right decision and so that's I
that's a very fundamental different
approach to looking and managing
patients if you haven't figured out yet
if you want to go into healthcare do it
because there's so many problems to
solve you will find one here today James
you mentioned earlier about innovation
continuing to occur in the US and
various members of the panel supported
that assertion that we still continue to
be the leader and will continue to be a
leader and then you also made a point
about cost being a larger consideration
now which is certainly true you see
examples like CMS and the FDA is sharing
more data now and so I'd like to get
some sense for how you see the course of
innovation changing and I asked that
because one example that I see is larger
emphasis on the D rather than the R with
say branded generics for example and so
I'd like to get a sense of what your
take on that would be thank you
with your first stab at that I think as
as the as this as this economic squeeze
starts to happen innovation becomes more
powerful because it's the only thing
that will retain pricing power there's
no reason we should have me to drugs I'm
going to say that I don't know I think
me to drugs are an expensive society
can't afford why should we spend
millions of dollars you build drugs that
are fundamentally identical drugs that
already exist
why don't we in reality have a
discussion about what the prices should
be for drugs that exist I don't I would
rather that money gets spent on new
drugs for new diseases than on simply
replicating what we already have
the reason people will go to me to drugs
is because they are attached to the
thought the me to drugs are less risky
which they are at least less risky to
get onto the marketplace but are they
less risky once they get there that's
decision or society has to make so I'm a
big believer that that innovation has
been important and it's going to get
even vastly more important over time as
the economic as the economic squeeze
occurs and it's pricing power for
generics and its pricing power for even
drugs that have minimal effect starts it
continues to collapse sorry has an auto
but where do you see that do you do
still see innovation happening at the
art stage then I mean do you see
absolutely yeah and R&D I mean
development you have to realize it in
the pharmaceutical industry development
and research are very closely and yield
to one another in the best of companies
because development is really that which
occurs after you've identified your
candidate and it's a scientific there
are some scientific questions as well as
eventually some economic questions
you're trying to answer in development
so the companies that are really good at
this the scientists and the developers
are talking to one another constantly as
the drugs going through its pre market
phase before it makes it onto the market
I think that will continue to be for
those companies that that will succeed a
continued expense twenty twenty-five
percent of revenue being spent on R&D I
think there's also a couple of trends
here to keep in mind and one is that
these things tend to happen in cycles
too so undoubtedly we're in a trough
we've been in troughs before as an
industry and we will be again which also
and means as greenspan used to say I
know rates will go up I know they'll
fall and I know those stay steady I just
can't tell you when so we will have a
surge in innovation a surgeon in
productive research and the fact of the
the human genome efforts that there'll
be there'll be surges in different areas
I think that's probably clear and
targeted medicine targeted therapies the
combination of Diagnostics with
therapeutics so there'll be different
areas of innovation the days of the
blockbuster you know are not gone but
they're certainly far more limited so
from a business model point of view
certainly at the larger company level
that's why Pfizer is talking about
breaking itself down so that their
investor expectations are reduced and
that's why I am genna's paying a
dividend
you know so that they can get another
class of investors to pay attention so
but fundamentally I mean I agree with
everything that's been set up here in
terms of the capacity for innovation the
drive for it the need for it the demand
for it because the demand is coming from
out there no it's not demand that's
internal within the companies I mean it
that happens but it happens because it's
driven by an insatiable appetite by our
country and our colleague countries for
for constantly improved healthcare and
that's not going to go away you know we
always think about innovation happening
in in isolation
there's always an enabling technology
you know whether we talk about genomics
it's a sequencing that in brought on the
concert it's almost like it's the
microscope that brought in the concept
of antibiotics and things of that nature
so there needs to be an enabling
technology and I in the way that I see
is that implement embryonic cell related
technologies for example GE healthcare
today is actually taking embryonic stem
cells and converting them to he
parasites and cardiomyocytes so that we
can begin to do screening at a human
cell level rather than the surrogate
animal models are in vitro targets that
that we've used so there's always some
new enabling technology that allows
somebody to look at the same problem
with a different light and the trough
that you're talking about is that when
we exhaust that new innovation begins to
come in so the way that I look at is
that some of the cell based technologies
is going to be the foundation on which
the new innovation and new ways of doing
things is going to happen one last
question thank you all for being here my
question is mainly to dawn but maybe
James can chime into this too one big
difference with biotech Joyce is that
yeah
coming along you know great innovation
but they are expensive to make you know
to produce you know to manufacture and
on top of that you know in order to get
them cheaper the ideas are with
biosimilars but there's a lot of you
know push and pull going on with the
biotechnology companies with this
biosimilars they're not really similar
they are not the same drug you know you
cannot get them approved and so forth so
how do you get these biotech drugs that
are expensive now cheaper so that you
know more people in the world can use
them and it's it's available to them
well I think I think Bala answered that
I think the answer is it's the next
level of innovation that will allow the
fermentation and culturing and and
purification and and production to scale
of a biologic product as opposed to a
little white pill that's made chemically
we may not have that capability right
now and in fact that is a big challenge
for the delivery of biologics into the
developing world but again I'm confident
that there will be a next level of
innovation that will facilitate that
because it's in it's everyone else it's
everyone's selfish interest to do that
in addition to their altruistic interest
to do that you know I sit on the board a
back on which is a very large company
with home with its partnering with all
the major companies Pfizer mile on etc
and what I see there is that if those
companies are no longer just looking at
bark on as a place where you can make
inexpensive biosimilars but more
importantly use that relationship you
know it's almost like Oscar Kennedy's
that question what can you do with this
relationship that you could not do
before so I think innovation is going to
be occurring across global we live in a
global village there are no geographic
boundaries and they are going to be the
catalyst that's going to bring in the
new ways of looking at developing things
differently executing on development
programs differently to make them
affordable the other thing that there's
plenty of room for innovation for is
beyond the the biologic production
techniques it's
for example there's a drug called
amphotericin B that's effective in
treating Leishman and leishmaniasis with
a single dose as opposed to a 30 to 45
day course of treatment that some of the
other drugs require well an fo B is a
little zonal delivery which is pretty
complicated but they figured out how to
get it and put it in a cold pack on the
back of a motorcycle so that it kill you
know about this bottle so it can be
transported into some of the remote
villages in India so it's not just
sometimes the production techniques
itself it's how do we think about the
the value chain how do we think about
delivering you know what is coke do to
get coca-cola into the most remote
village you'd ever find in Africa or
Asia and what can we learn from that how
can we think outside the box there so
there's room for that as well let me
just make one comment the reason that
the drugs are expensive is not because
they're expensive to manufacture and
that's true for biologics as well as
small molecules biologics are more
expensive to manufacture than small
molecules but the real reason is because
the right now it costs us about 1.8
billion dollars to put a drug under the
market it's not 800 million the way the
TUF study suggests that it was a number
of decades ago it's probably more like
1.8 billion and some studies have linked
to that number may be as great as 3.5
billion so the reason that drugs are
expensive is because the attrition rate
is so high it turns out that for
biologics the attrition rate is half
that of the trician rate of small
molecules so in reality it's much
cheaper to develop and sell biologic for
most of the lifecycle of that product
than it is a small molecule the answer
your question about how to make them
more expensive the most powerful ways to
increase the likelihood that it's going
to succeed in development let me offer
just one more thought on that - and
there's another way to come at the
problem completely which is to provide
other sources of support and incentives
so on things like the advanced market
commitment a pre-arranged volume
purchase commitment on the part of
funding governments so that companies
who are producing the the vaccine in
question will actually do it Priority
Review voucher z' that some of the other
incentives support coming through Gavi
or the the airline tax that pays
to help reduce these costs and the
bigger theme on that to me is that this
is a multilateral problem this is not a
problem that the drug companies can
solve or should be asked to solve on
their own that's not rational it's not
reasonable or fair so there has to be a
multilateral approach to this and again
I come back to the fact that the global
health spending in its entirety is a
tiny sliver of what's spent on the
for-profit R&D sector and there needs to
be more support from governments and
other agencies thank you
well this brings the it brings us to the
end of the panel and actually to the end
of the conference today I hope you've
all enjoyed being here at Stanford this
has been a fascinating day and I want to
thank our panel I think they have capped
it off with everything from drug pricing
science innovation the role of the u.s.
to evolution in Darwin so thank you very
much